[Music]
so we've got a list here of some common
things that you might do that might be
driving your co-workers crazy yeah or if
you're wondering why you want to switch
jobs these
annoying
habits
may be trying to drive yet you think you
want to change careers and you just need
a new location because you work with
people that's right you want to jump off
of a cliff and here's the thing so we
got a list caveat this it can be really
difficult to approach a co-worker when
they're bothering you something because
you don't want to start the conflict and
go hey ken you got to stop clipping your
toes you know what i like maybe we'll
address how you would approach some of
these but let's let's dive in here okay
um
uh how about the person who uh
who walks through the office or sits
near you
and they hum or see the hummer the
hummer or the singer yeah out of nowhere
they bring you into a song they've got a
song in their heart and they want
everyone to know and by the way have you
ever noticed that these people james
they never start at the start of the
song it's always like the song's going
in their head and they just kind of pick
it up mid-verse and we're all left to go
what what's happening here they hit the
chorus these people that they oh uh
james brought up one the whistler
oh man the whistle while you work we
don't want nobody likes a whistler
that's nails on a chalkboard
but see i think it's all the same the
singer the people who are humming all
the time it's a lot of self-awareness is
what it is yeah i don't want to be
brought into your personal soundtrack
that's a good good line right there okay
how about this one ken people who listen
to music without headphones
because they're playlists so good yeah
yeah put some headphones on and you know
what secondary on airplanes
put some headphones on yeah if you're in
any public space
put some headphones on it's 20 22.
they're cheap i always love the old dude
on the airplane who forgets about the
concept of the headphones and he starts
the movie and it's so loud because he's
deaf anyway that we hear it all the way
in the back of the airplane yikes yeah
headphones are good
all right next up uh okay
here's my how about the people that
reply all to emails when they shouldn't
oh or they don't reply all when they
[ __ ] in other words
they just don't have any common sense
around emails the kids call that cringe
is that what they call it yeah cringe
here's the one that drives me nuts
uh james was talking to me about this
and he's right
how about the person who replies with
emojis all the time or gifts yeah do you
call them gifts or jim a gift guy
gifford jiff in the control room gif i
like a well-placed gif but it's the
people who just only reply in them and
you can't get an actual answer out of
them yeah they have nothing to say right
it's like they're a puppet they won't be
real for any moment of time and yeah
i'll tell you the one that drives me is
the last word person they always got to
get the last word oh it's clear that the
email chain is done we've resolved our
business and they gotta fire one more
unnecessary thx exclamation point like
we all need one more email what i love
is they didn't have the time to just do
the a-n-k right but they had time to
send one more meaningless email
here's the deal nobody ever needs to do
the unnecessary thank you less emails in
2022 what else you got george this one
gets me cause i'm
guilty holding a door for you when
you're too far away and so you feel like
you have to run because the person is
just standing there waiting for you yes
okay and by the way have you ever
noticed that person has always got this
big smile on their face like they're
doing you a big favor
right like you're incapable of opening
the door i know you're a long way away
but i'm such a stellar human being that
i'm going to hold this right and it has
the opposite effect doesn't it what does
it do to you when you see that door open
from that far away it feels like my
middle school soccer coach going let's
see some hustle camel come on
let's go pick them up pick them up right
it's very frustrating so here's my
parameter ken either you've got to be
holding things to where you can't open
the door and then i'm happy to open it
right if you're holding a bunch of stuff
i feel bad i'll hold it for 15-30
seconds and if you're 10 feet away i go
all right that's the parameter if you're
more than 10 feet
just be on your way i'll open the door
myself yeah you're not a big jerk yeah
yeah i'll be kind we're not saying don't
be kind but don't make it awkward all
right george moving on here's one that i
think the whole world at work can
sympathize with and that is
the disgusting
awful grotesque food that stinks up the
entire floor not just the break room or
the kitchen i mean it seeps throughout
the entire building hey no one should
ever eat fish at work ever
ever it's a dangerous mood i don't even
care if it's fish sticks from long john
silver's no fish people are getting fish
sticks
on silvers is that still somebody's got
fast fast food we've got a list here in
case you're wondering what are those
other foods we got fish we got
sauerkraut brussels sprouts by the way
chicken gizzard no one's eating chicken
giving for lunch
oh james is pointing to someone in the
control room well someone who is someone
who had that experience not that did it
oh so somebody on our team which shall
remain nameless brought chicken gizzard
which by the way i didn't even know what
chicken gizzard is i don't know where to
buy that it was at a previous job so
thankfully it's no one here oh thank you
for the caveat james clear don't want to
offend anybody here at ramsay solutions
what is gizzard am i allowed to ask that
is that
it's a part of a chicken i never want to
touch or eat
that's it hey here's a general rule of
thumb if you don't know what part of the
animal it comes off of you might not eat
it
right is that fair hey i want to go back
a step brussels sprouts is on my top
three awful smells of all time wow
okay so save it do it at home
good job
yeah not eating around can now i will
say we've got a cafeteria here at ramsey
solutions so there's a lot more
places for the smells to go it's a big
open area back in the old days we had
tiny you know the tiny little kitchens
and break rooms not a lot of place for
the smell to go so be kind who's up next
on the list is it you or me i think it's
me oh yeah i was talking about the awful
smells i'm gonna put this one out there
okay
sales folks who talk very loudly oh on
the
when you because you've got that this
world-class technology a lot of the
sales people wearing these kind of deals
right not quite as big a mic and then
they got to go over the top 17 people
all talking with their outdoor voices a
lot of fake laughs too
sales best fake laughers all time oh
yeah they'll laugh at anything laugh at
anything give you a and by the way not
just a laugh a guffaw you know what a
guffaw is that's a
leave it to ken for a ten dollar word
for laugh gefa is like a chesty laugh
right we're we're heaving a lot of
volume a lot of shaking you're are you a
gaffare no okay hurts yeah it's not
healthy for you okay here's one how
about uh how about booking a meeting
room uh that could fit 30 people when
there's three people that one is
hilarious to walk by it's kind of
obnoxious yeah where do we sit there's
too many decisions i have to make prior
to the meeting that's true there's
plenty meeting rooms around here yeah
yeah yeah uh now a few things that
didn't make this list this was kind of
compiled by some uh
the conference call etiquette you know
the zoom like like so when the pandemic
hit like everybody was on zoom or
whatever your platform is for video
calls
drives me nuts
you got romper room going around in the
back right a lot of distractions i don't
want to be into your life you have
invited me into your life and what we're
supposed to be doing is having a meeting
is the blur feature where it blurs the
background see i didn't even know that
existed it does because here's what i do
ken i'm judging everything in their
house i'm going oh wow that's so true
how am i supposed to pay attention when
you've invited me into your life it's
too much for me i can't i can't i can't
process it yeah i hate i hate meetings
anyway just as a general rule i walk
into meetings going i hate this and then
i hope it's good i just hate the
unnecessary meetings our friend patrick
loncione's got the book death by meeting
it's a great book and so the meetings
that could have been an email sometimes
people just want to hear themselves talk
in the room and that's why we go let's
let's circle up let's meet we'll circle
back
circle by circling see now you're going
into a potential another list that's for
another day and that's overused office
jargon well you know what i'm talking
about where people just wear it out
circle back is a big one yeah another
one is i don't have a bandwidth
bandwidth bandwidth
band from all jargon band bandwidth yeah
there it is
hey if you are doing any of those things
you need to stop it immediately this is
the takeaway yeah because you are the
annoying obnoxious person that know what
he wants to be around so you know we all
have room for growth ken has called you
guys out now luckily we work with a lot
of great folks at ramsey solutions this
stuff happens very sparingly yeah james
only does about two of those this is
james's personal list of things that
you bother him i do yeah this is an
email from james going ken i'd really
like you to improve in these areas good
stuff